do you feel like you guys are starting
to develop more and more responsibility
in the sense that as more and more
people are watching you now you've got
to have these or you choose to have
these political people on your show you
got Octavia Cortez on your show you got
booty jig on your show you got you know
candidates are coming on your show yeah
you're talking to young people and it
used to be just a thing where we goof on
whatever we goof on now do you feel like
you actually have to educate people
here's this person we're presenting them
to you out of their element
like you know they're hanging out with
us who are not clearly like the furthest
thing from political pundits so you can
[ __ ] find on TV right so it's like I
this guy is gonna come over here and
hang out with us in our hood so you're
gonna see how he reacts in this
situation in this environment and then
you decide whatever the [ __ ] you wanna
decide yes more about weirdness because
like we're not there like what's your
position on this with your position oh
here's this person they're running if
you want to find out more about them
find out more about them this is what
they did this afternoon with those we're
never gonna be honest or like vote for
this person like you say it's not your
responsibility our job is not to [ __ ]
educate people just like yo you have a
job I was like no that's not our job if
you want to find out more about these
politicians like my MSNBC you like it's
my job to educate you in seven minutes
about this person who possibly president
of the country hell no that's not our
job we're going to make jokes and point
out bloopers on viral clips we ate sushi
we dragon apart broad I don't know if
that's like in any of issues that you
want to talk about you always get people
were like oh you had this person on your
show you didn't ask him about this yeah
like yeah let's just stop our interview
to talk about like the low birthrate of
black women that's randomly like there's
certain things we're not equipped to
handle and this is like if you tune in
to our show expecting that you were
watching the wrong show all right child
of my boy Chris Hayes he has a whole
hour you see where they ask questions
like that we're not getting like now
this be a weird question and people will
ask questions like that you just like yo
what exactly is your goal you're just
complaining the complain because these
candidates go on 20 shows a day mm-hmm
days someone else is gonna ask that
question in your beef and now we didn't
ask like don't we're not gonna know but
you can ask him about Handy's yeah
that's how you come near that show and
you get ya anything about Handy's and
things like that and then if you want
[ __ ] politics of [ __ ] go over to
c-span yeah a lot of places to get that
is gonna ask you have Wenzel for last
time you got a double blow job
right and I want to know on that visual
of Bernie Sanders getting double [ __ ]
you know the answer is if he's still
doing it now I want to know that it's
still happening I want to know how much
future I have helping with the polls oh
my god if you found out they just had a
double blow job two nights ago
would actually lose in the standing well
like you have to assume mayor Pete is
young enough that he should be getting
double blow jobs right Joe Biden strikes
me as a very sexual man who would it who
would it hurt though and would it hurt
some reason I think the Blasio all the
balls balls balls don't the balls
yeah people would hate it but it doesn't
matter what de Blasio says people hate
him him and his son that fake
conversation they voted once he ate
Sbarro's pizza backwards with a fork it
was like oh yeah what is so hateable
about we talked about this morning he's
just you look at me was a lot of things
if you're in New York if you're born
abroad New Yorker you see this guy come
in he becomes the mayor of New York City
he's a [ __ ] Red Sox fan he doesn't
know how to eat pizza
these are little these are small things
that are really big things you don't say
in a phony personality like Bloomberg
was like [ __ ] I'm rich as [ __ ] yeah
every other mayor has had like swag
every other mayor has kind of had this
like indignant like I don't like you New
Yorkers I'm better than you like you
guys should be honored I'm even talking
to you a little Fife and Koch was very
cocky yeah yeah tennis wasn't right
fathers just like hey I'm shoveling my
own this is jerk [ __ ] like randomized
video game character that you just like
you randomized a mayor
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app